[Musica]
parlare di casa e parlare di accoglienza
di quella accoglienza che abbiamo
desiderato avere quando siamo venuti al
mondo e anche di protezione perché la
casa è anche protezione
basta guardare un bambino quando
comincia a camminare
subito si metterà sotto un tavolo
cercherà protezione e da quello spazio
che lui ha costruito guarderà il mondo
immaginerà che cosa vedere del mondo
la casa è anche identitaria perché non
c'è niente di più identitario che una
casa la casa e molte cose io mi sono
occupata di case perché penso che capire
il nostro modo di abitarlo a fondo sia
molto importante
io sono una psicoterapeuta che ha
lavorato per molto tempo con la
patologia infantile
ho cominciato con gli adulti poi sono
andata con gli adolescenti e poi sono
arrivata ai bambini molto piccoli
ho preso questa strada perché ho visto
dalle storie degli adulti che avevano
anche delle patologie che c'era qualcosa
che era successo nei primi anni di vita
e che aveva reso fragile la struttura e
quindi la struttura psicologica e per
questo ho dovuto occuparmi chiaramente
della costruzione dell'identità perché
la costruzione dell'identità e proprio
si crea proprio dei primi anni di vita e
naturalmente di occuparmi di questi
primi anni e della relazione dei bambini
con i loro genitori
la casa è anche identitaria perché basta
guardare le case per capire come sono le
persone
e proprio questa finita
tra identità tra psicologia e
architettura che proprio mi ha fatto
appassionare alla psicologia
dell'abitare abitare gli spazi tutti gli
spazi di spazi del mondo del lavoro gli
spazi della cura di spazi e della casa
perché penso che la casa sia un potente
strumento terapeutico per curarci basta
vedere quando stiamo male la prima cosa
che facciamo mettere a posto le case
pulirle ordinarle mettere a posto gli
armadi però la casa ci fa anche scoprire
qualcosa di diverso di noi qualcosa di
sconosciuto a casa si costruisce
esattamente come la nostra identità per
costruire una casa solida è anche bella
ci vuole un progetto ci vuole uno studio
del terreno e è anche una qualità è una
quantità di cemento affettivo di ag
cemento scusate che sia sole che sia
giusto per le fondazioni
se c'è la cura di tutto questo la casa
verrà su solida non ci saranno problemi
si potrà riparare ma non crollerà anche
per la nostra identità per quello che
noi siamo ci vorrà un progetto poi
bisognerà conoscere la nostra storia
familiare
il nostro transgenerazionale e ci vorrà
anche qui una qualità e una quantità di
cemento questo affettivo per darci
quella sicurezza per superare gli
scossoni e scossoni della vita
inevitabili questo è necessario ma prima
ancora questo ci darà la nostra
sicurezza e prima quando parlo di
progetto e gli architetti stanno bene
cosa vuol dire progetto io parlo anche
di quello spazio immaginario
che precede la nostra venuto al mondo è
che è molto importante quello spazio di
réverie di sogno che è fondamentale per
creare quello spazio di accoglienza dove
noi ci sentiremmo veramente di avere
veramente bene nella mia esperienza chi
non ha avuto questo spazio per motivi se
y perché è venuto al mondo quando non
era ancora un momento non si voleva un
figlio oppure dopo un lutto
sarà una persona che abiterà male il
mondo che avrà fatica
noi ci costruiamo attraverso lo sguardo
dell'altro
lo sguardo di nostra madre è la nostra
prima accoglienza e quando c'è uno
sguardo incerto per motivi magari la
madre depressa la persona si costruirà
con questo sguardo il bambino che è
assolutamente percettivo siamo tutti
molto istintivi all'inizio lo dovremmo
essere tuttora ma il bambino lo è può
anche rispondere con subito con un
sintomo che non vuol dire che è una cosa
patologica per esempio un bambino che
sente che la mamma è depressa può anche
rifiutare di bere isolate non vuole bere
un latte macchiato di tristezza questo
non vuol dire che il bambino è
problematico anzi è un bambino un
bambino molto sensibile e la mamma che
bisogna aiutarla che deve essere aiutato
e qualche volta basta molto poco
basta parlare con questa mamma per
sbloccare uno spazio ingombrato da altro
quindi lo spazio mentale è veramente
molto importante perché è la prima
accoglienza
quello che noi siamo quindi dipende da
tutto questo e molte volte quando non lo
abbiamo avuto
ci sentiremo come delle persone fuori
luogo nella ricerca in erranza continua
di trovare qualcosa che ci contiene e
quindi la casa che in sé e accoglienza
non sarà solamente non saranno solo dei
metri quadri ma molto di più
pareti che ci proteggono finestre che ci
fanno guardare oltre se ci siamo sentiti
soffocati bagni che ci possono contenere
nella cura del nostro corpo e
un'intimità che forse non abbiamo avuto
cucina e salvifiche che riparano un cibo
che non è andato bene il cibo primario
ripostigli che nascondono le nostre
insicurezze
voglio solo rispoli un ripostiglio le
case racchiudono in sé tanti sogni ed i
fatti
basta vedere che quando uno sceglie una
casa molto spesso è scelta come un conte
futuro voglio quella è solo quella
perché in realtà c'è una condensazione
di ricordi di passato e presente che è
difficile da capire molto difficile da
capire
e però la casa rappresenta veramente il
nostro spazio interiore
pensiamo per esempio alle camere degli
adolescenti quelle che atterriscono
tutti i genitori
questa è veramente un esempio di come
nello spazio fisico si rappresenta un
caos mentale è normale l'adolescente ha
bisogno di quel caos perché hai un caos
l'adolescenza è un passaggio da un mondo
ad un altro e quindi questo caos
e giusto e lui ha bisogno quindi
chiudiamo le camere degli adolescenti
rispettiamo il bisogno di ognuno di
sentirsi rappresentato di sentire
rappresentato il mondo interno di uno
spazio esterno
c'è chi ha bisogno dei cuscini tutti
allineati che ha bisogno di altro pur
che ognuno abbia proprio spazio
pensiamo anche ai carcerati
non so se avete mai visto qualche
reportage i carcerati che vivono in
celle sovraffollate hanno bisogno ognuno
di avere il proprio angolo personale che
lo personalizzano e se non
diventerebbero impazzirebbero quindi
molto importante la comprensione di
questo bisogno ma c'è un'ulteriore
assonanza tra il corpo della casa come
si dice un architettura e il nostro
corpo che proprio si ritrova
simbolicamente nelle stanze che sono
proprio pervase da investite da una
pulsione quella pulsione che ci investe
dei primi anni di vita proprio in un
percorso che va dalla dipendenza alla
autonomia quando noi nasciamo siamo
spinti da una forza vitale proprio una
pulsione vitale che investe delle parti
del nostro corpo
la prima la pulsione orale è quella che
fa attaccare al seno un bambino la
possiamo anche di vedere da come abbiamo
costituito arredato progettato le nostre
stanze lo vedremo nella cucina le nostre
cucine come sono delle degli spazi
attrezzati dove si trova tutto dove si
fa veramente da mangiare o qualcosa
diciamo di poco pensato c'è chi dice
anche io la cucina
vorrei dentro un armadio ecco a seconda
di come abbiamo fatto le nostre cucine
pensate ci sarà il rapporto ha come
abbiamo vissuto noi il nostro rapporto
primario poi c'è la pulsione anale che
dal bambino va dai 2 anni e 34 e lì c'è
la conoscenza del corpo la
consapevolezza di che cos'è questo corpo
prima il bambino era solamente una bocca
che mangiavano conosceva il proprio
corpo poi invece c'è una maturazione un
controllo sfinterico e dove si si può
rispecchiare tutto questa cura del corpo
nel bagno in questa spazi e spazio dove
noi chiudiamo la porta dove noi ci
guardiamo allo specchio dove noi capiamo
come stiamo
dove utilizziamo anche l'acqua
quest'acqua di cui abbiamo memoria
perché tutti noi abbiamo avuto un
passato intrauterino bene i nostri bagni
saranno un'accozzaglia di oggetti
confusi o saranno dei tempi un piccolo
tempio per il nostro benessere che cura
abbiamo avuto per il nostro corpo e che
cura diamo ora nelle nostre stanze e poi
questa pulsione va ai genitali si chiama
pulsione genitale e porta il bambino
alla scoperta dell'altro nell'inno cento
gioco del dottore nel non è più
concentrato su se stesso guarda come
sono fatti gli altri e possiamo vederla
raffigurata in un'altra stanza alla
stanza da letto dove diciamo il presidio
un po dell'incontro con l'altro della
relazione sessuale della nostra
sessualità come sono le nostre stanze da
bagno sono delle celle monacali o sono
delle alcove
clienti e proprio questo rapporto intimo
tra casa e spazio tra mondo interno e
bisogni primari che ci darà una
fotografia di noi di quello che ci piace
ma anche di quello che ci manca di
quello che è bloccato e quindi anche con
la possibilità di riparazione perché la
casa grazie a dio
ricordate lo è uno strumento terapeutico
incredibile per farci vedere come siamo
ma per farci anche cambiare qualche cosa
e poi c'è un'altra cosa che mi interessa
molto comunicarvi che capire il nostro
senso dell'abitare perché ci sono molte
persone che abitano in una maniera
indifferente le proprie case quelle case
per esempio che sono tutte perfette fate
un po dagli architetti non voglio dire
niente contro gli architetti ma c'è
gente che ci sono persone che non hanno
coraggio di mostrare il loro sentire ed
è un peccato perché potrebbero capire
attraverso il progetto attraverso il
cantiere molto di loro stessi e ci sono
anche patologie dell'abitare in progetti
che non si riesce mai a portare a
termine o in casa e che non sono mai
finite
oppure in casa che finite poi alla fine
ci lasciano sempre scontenti e questo
dipende dalla nostra storia
quindi conoscere la nostra storia è
molto importante ci dà un senso anche a
certe cose che non capiamo e adesso io
vorrei farvi vedere un video proprio per
capire il senso profondo dell'abitare un
video che dura pochissimi può un poco
più di un minuto per farvi capire il
senso
nell'acqua proprio per sardi fare mente
locale la vostra stanza da bagno che è
un luogo che tutti abbiamo ma che a
volte usiamo in maniera indifferente vi
ricordate tempo fa c'era la moda delle
vasche idromassaggio che magari qualcuno
comperato e poi è la prima rottura ha
lasciato la perché perché era uno status
symbol e quindi non avevamo capito il
senso profondo dell'acqua
noi abbiamo dentro le nostre case dentro
una stanza che è incredibilmente
terapeutica che il bagno perché perché
c'è l'acqua è vero che ci guardiamo e
vero che capiamo come funzioniamo ma c'è
questo elemento che è fondamentale
allora io vorrei farvi vedere questo
video e sono sicura che dopo aver visto
questo video voi cambierete spero il
modo di prendere un bagno o di fare una
doccia
vorrei farvi capire che cosa vuol dire a
riprendere quello che abbiamo già
vissuto avere rilassarsi accettare
questo questa rilassatezza grazie
all'acqua quell'acqua di cui abbiamo
memoria storica
[Musica]
ecco questo questa specie di stato di
nirvana che avete visto in questa
bambina possiamo averla anche noi se
dedichiamo un po più di tempo al nostro
momento dell'acqua di ogni mattina o di
ogni sera non basterà andare nelle spa
ma solamente avere la consapevolezza del
nostro modo profondo di abitare con
questo per me è capire il senso delle
nostre stanze utilizzare appieno la
nostra la nostra casa
abitare per avvitarsi a fondo guardare
le nostre case e capire chi siamo
capire anche quello che abbiamo bloccato
semplicemente negato capire in fondo di
quello che abbiamo bisogno grazie
[Applauso]